- You guys, look at my pimple!
It's so gross, it's like a
planet on my face is forming.
- Yeah, that's kind of nasty.
Seriously?
- Yeah.
- Ugh, okay.
- [Voiceover] Wait, what did I say?
- Oh, there's new one.
Welcome to the family, I'm
going to call you Donald.
- Have you tried washing your face though?
- Of course I wash my face!
Yes, I always wash my face.
- Oooh, you should try ProActiv.
- You know, I was reading
all of this stuff online and
basically, you should go vegan.
- Are you (bleeping) kidding me?
Please, please, I just
need something to work.
- Every, everyday though, not just like
every week or something?
- This guy, yeah.
- Hey, you know, make-up
is bad for your skin.
You shouldn't put a lot of it on.
- Well, my skin is pretty
bad for my skin, so I don't
know why I shouldn't hide my skin.
Hmm, maybe I should
use skin-clearing apps.
Ugh, that does not look like me.
I wish I had her skin.
I bet she only has only
has one kind of soap.
Maybe all of my Instagrams
could just be my drawings.
- He always throws like the craz...
Oh, my god, Emma, did you draw that?
- Yeah.
- Oh my god, do you see this?
- That's so good!
- Emma, that is bov!
- It's not that bad,
you're a stand-up person.
You've got friends, you
don't look like Shrek.
It could be worse.
Oh, Donald's left, sweet!
They're not going to be
there forever, I'm fine.
- If you don't wash it
every night, you're going to
have any acne, that's
why I don't get acne,
because I wash my face.
- Yes, Henry, night
and day I wash my face.